I'm sure the people who made this game
was still getting money first 18 years
theology you know what sure yeah sure
evil bastard cash
hello I'm like I'm trying to makanda to
be clean live streaming show where I
play a different random video game
this week's random video game as
supplied by GameSpot users psycho to may
darkness is solid I have never heard of
this game in my life it's called bad
mojo we are playing the Redux virgin
this game came out in 96 some sort of
FMV cockroach puzzle game I'm not really
sure and this Redux version came out in
oh so this this version is 10 years old
but this game is actually a lot older
than I was 18 years old so I don't know
I haven't a clue so just go straight
into it I'm kind of interested and
confused and weirded out already the
icon is cockroach it all right get away
go green screens are never not fun
taystee cockroach and all right
preferences sure yep why not why not
just have a dialog box for the settings
cancel help help me all right
this is traitor that's probably the
start of the game we'll do that later if
it's not already a mini intro okay
let's see if this intro makes things
more clear or less clear it's in 4:3 so
all my life I've felt helpless cheated
stepped on uh I was always the little
man the square pick the Forgotten one so
dark but that night
everything was gonna change sky just did
one pasta sauce over just sitting around
accepting my fate a rathole apartment a
dead-end job so I decided to do
something about it
he's got to prevent a terrorist attack
all right I'm guessing New York
perfect plan
my destination untrackable
the stolen cash Oh traceable yeah I'd
simply disappear into the night
of course there was a hitch a fly in the
ointment or should I say roach
this is flow couple my bags were all
packed and ready tickets passport a
change of clothes a cat he forgot to put
the cat in the box there you go
I was no longer the victim this time I
was in control what the [ __ ] going on
by Sunrise superbe on a plane in Mexico
in my home with a big smile on my face
and a small fortune nestled at my feet
if it wasn't for my idiot landlord I'd
be there right now sipping margaritas
and basking in the warm glow of a job
the rest of atomism not even real money
here this hour
Eddie where's my freaking red Sam's
you'll get the rent in the morning your
rents three days late okay what happened
to the light again slice me old man seto
get it in the morning looks like you're
packing up for a trip you should pay
your rent you've got like I'm yeah I'm
skipping out thousands in your briefcase
if I pay now get the hell out of here
and leave me alone
nurse we die
I'll leave you alone this looks like the
guy who's in that VHS sound stereo
student roach-infested all right you got
a light and don't bother me again it's
enough a lot of money to have laying
around in this neighborhood and your
doors open maybe next time you might
want a lock in that it's not funny honey
the guy from home oh good it's good
advice a t-table readies this will
happen to his career immediately after
home alone not accompany him yeah okay
stop masturbating over your money and
just go to the airport now go to a hotel
where's your cash
forget to lock it
guys this is actually a video game where
am I just watching a movie
I had the locket that looks like I think
crazy happened when I looked at that ha
ha ha that strange locket that was
supposed to be my mother's a weird
feeling like a twisting spell
Joe
seemingly completely disconnected from
the rest of the story he's real
my random locks buckled and then there
was black the war and somehow comforting
feeling of darkness
your mother was a cockroach the whole
time a long and perilous detour into the
night of my soul
okay sure
there's a lot of habitual drug use in
the 90s
all right you just love me like this CG
yeah
sure my insight is I this is the game
the game happening really all right
I'm controlling this rock and roll
racing style where I'm pressing up to go
forwards all right where will I go in
the sewer of my brain is a cigarette
smoke it it's like you're a cockroach
you can smoking cigarettes is like a
real cheap pasta nope not that way
this appears to be a foot print a bottle
cap
my man and I wanted a video game no yeah
it matches I can light that cigarette
finally let me going name
Oh
can I I go to Eddie's on the waterfront
as a cockroach
yeah those stuff possibly seeming more
cigarettes oh Jesus
it's not good what is that having
crawling around outside of it are they
just like that liquid whatever it is
hey more cigarettes Oh maybe if I push
this cigarette pack jump I'm just going
to jump right I once woke up with a
cockroach like beside my head in a place
I lived in and sat in London which is
really awful
it was ticking it was like it woke me up
it was like clicking behind my ear get
up there
oh hey cockroach friends what's up Hey
what
I'm having an existential caca wind
whatever suck you into the belly of a
beast its blowhole will catapult you to
the south and to the east one way there
is peril hardship and dismay one way
brings you closer to the deme concussion
but there is another option another
clever tack you may evade the wings
machine with a bold high wire act okay
it's not the other cockroach telling me
that
hey what's going on this is some sort of
insect orgy
my tentacles my tentacles
good night this is the most painfully
90s thing I've ever played okay I appear
to be underneath some sort of stove I
should probably walk into the flame
well okay I have a certain mental lives
if I should do that
keep going take more cockroach friends
hey dude
right
you guys know anything about a blowhole
and a high-wire act Oh
having a hard time figuring with what's
going on here
I'm gonna go in there just fall off your
cockroach gravity won't kill you choose
the lights all
there's the blast ematic I see it over
there
Oh
all right
weird FMV cockroach figured out it's
some sort of adventure game puzzle
pretty sure there's no mother but whoa
but a safe you want to lose my cockroach
from oh you were kidding me wow really
alright Jesus Christ and dog pmj my
underscore save down
mr. Christ
hey what's up you guys were of no help
to me going this way I didn't go I
didn't go at SAP but I got a damn
trains go that way
but my cigarette
oh I can't because the water
let's think about the other way for this
way
back here
all I can't go into different ones
awesome alright how many are there
these are locked don't you
no what what didn't I turn around four
times already
what
deepa confusing I want to smoke a
cigarette it's okay I'm not above
smoking filters more cigarettes
really really why I gotta let strip club
again that's got a game guide for this
bad mojo game guys jerk game boomers
let's try you yeah I got we did that bit
already yeah
Roger though okay his name is Roger the
roach great helpful tip save often I've
already done that
advance to get every room I feel like
I've already done that start at your
serger and to find your way to the human
force you are in a sewer pipe that's
correct
go straight up the blue leg of the water
here into the pipe where a number of
your disgusting peer group are gathered
I like it this guy's editorializing the
game go watch the cutscene where the
roaches talk to you is that what happens
turn right on small pipe across the
burning gas jet said that absolutely
like oh you're good and the like okay
using game guides is not cheating now
there's a that is a part parts of
playing games in the 90s because they
are so hard I want to talk to anyone who
tells me they've played they lead a grim
fandago that using a game guys
I'm not this [ __ ] again I don't care
I don't care
Johnny Five is alive to lean yeah nobody
cares stupid hot drunken talks people
but down this life
yes oh god you're all dead
this is deeply awful oh it's like a
sticky pad
oh Jesus Christ this game is the worst
yeah rot some blood is too thick that's
blood is thicker than water
hey what's up what's wrong with your
face oh Jesus Christ it's good this [ __ ]
all right
I think I've only got two lives left
and then nibble on your town a teabag
your town
get off the thing oh Jesus
we got one life left saved
it all good stuff for cigarette always a
spider that's entire flight I'm out of
here
it's a spider trying to have a cigarette
that was going on
yeah you have a smoke you got any smokes
Jonnie Jonnie smokes kind of a puff of
this well you might want to sister last
one
I just want to spoil drugs give me
dragon it badges
yeah
so that's what happens in cockroaches
die okay
oh you think I'm going back there
you think I'll go back there video game
I'm gonna load my game there it is I
need to open this I bet it's just like a
tiny config file that says
you meet I want to open it in your ward
Doc's notepad
really
the
turn or drop-off Oh God okay it's not
must be a bad mojo fan site somewhere
that has all these six save games I go
this way this time Jesus thought sticky
paper everything in this world is so
sticky all these guys are stuck
this [ __ ] rod is sticky
today
this spider wants to have a smoke but
I'm gonna go [ __ ] up his bread first I
feel like I'm supposed to set his web on
fire with the same go this way I'm
losing I'm respawning
making backups making backups I feel
like the what the [ __ ] what how why I'm
over here what happened there
why am I in the web what
it's a good thing I saved all right that
was weird
sir pull Buffy near have a smoke you'll
feel better about everything have a
smoke
all right good thing I have this on the
next great save your game and avoid
pointing the road straps go right to the
lighted cigarette blunt and quickly push
it so the lighted end is pointed at the
spider you need to move fast here before
the spider gets you and you're
successful the nasty spider is toast
take it from me kids this is not a game
you want to play hold over here we go oh
god I have to do quicker than that all
right
I'm focusing
can I not do this now because is it like
impossible to win this man because he's
here and I go up here and come over here
let's do this real quick no [ __ ] that up
but I made it way harder to do it this
time
Dark Soul assistance okay I have to go
through that nonsense and every single
time I'm gonna load this one I got more
likes
hey what's up you guys tried that spider
does not want to smoke a cigarette
hey guys what's up hey [ __ ] ride the
crawl up you again okay okay here we go
first of all save the video game over
like this the MJ file I got a book it
for the nasty spider gets me come on
no it'll get stuck you idiot cut that
off a [ __ ] sake
what the [ __ ] was that smoke on that
yeah that's right
okay
I did that thing again where I'm off the
other side it's great
Jesus Christ this game isn't word to the
wise do not
you're not low could save the game in
this area sock spider
another dead thing is this we're gonna
eat me when I run over its face as well
cockroach Parral I'll go in there it's a
trick I'm gonna go in there
okay it's going on for the party you got
going on here blue I asked about getting
some drugs I crawled over this
cockroach's body I can
this is dark
when I like that thing in the middle
that is gonna staying away
and crawled over these dead cockroaches
this is just a really unpleasant video
game I'm not enjoying being in this
world don't know what that is it looks
like a human finger I'm gonna crawl over
this guy who's not dead yes this guy
who's who's dead you dead can I crawl
now
I use this to kill doc cockroach
I just crawled over you just let me
crawl over you you're dead anyway
just let me 69 you
right asking my good friend
that spider on the second screen call
then full length with rats cats go to
the third screen the infamous cockroach
Corral it's so infamous I've never heard
of it
turn and go forward into the cockroach
Corral you need to get across the maze
cockroach growls solution the green
liquid is not poison to you the pink
walkway are yeah yeah yeah
staying in the well push the little
purple white larva over to the dead
Roach at the top and climb over them
both all right so I was on the right I
was thinking just commentation
this game is awful hey go snuck in on
his head obviously I'm out
goodbye cockroach Corral wait
we're gonna have
stinky favor of this leg got that leg
yeah also get ant and silverfish weird
a lot of a lot of hangnails here
seemingly no reason I don't know why
there would be agnez there all right
wrote rate not on my watch
yeah this way electrical cable just what
animals will be allowed to be used in
the labs along with penalties from the
forecast shallots his cigarettes alarms
may with strong southwesterly winds to
37 miles per hour and will have a high
of 59 degrees with the temperature
dropping rapidly towards this evening
the showers and thunderstorms expected
to continue into tomorrow night low rain
tampering this guy appears to live in
the 20s hey come on up and pick up the
cash that bastard Sam's what a pain in
the ass
looks like I'm gonna have to get a new
tenant
maybe you can live there instead of in
this basement I believe it enough off
the guitar basic that you should
probably get out of here it'll be hard
to hard to automate you in the video
game everyday likes going to a strip
club
all right
it's green goo this time what color of
goo will be in the next level for you
I mean wanna know what that is art paint
I thought I supposed to get something
the prophecy said gets up there I don't
tell me it's safe
speedrun at this time look at checkout
the six-speed one this has busy get
stuck immediately what you can do it
what's the record for fastest speed run
up bad mojo I'm gonna do a speed run of
the cockroach ground we go we go we've
seen both yo same pole is this larva
get in there yes
it's time I'm gonna go straight up the
leg
just what animals will be allowed to be
used as are no record and had break
while this is on because I filled body
of [ __ ] it gets of probably good driver
with the Africa
stick around Oh for more bad mojo game
guides
according to horsies in the chat the
speed run for this is two hours 50
minutes so not including cutscenes
speaking of which
we get Jimmy to cool
I'm not supposed to go into the thing
I'm gonna crawl up this instead
I really hate cockroaches is the worst
game you play
alright I'm gonna eat this thing is that
completely pointless being under this
why is it even there I don't know I've
got it I think this this game boomers
walkthrough is my favourite thing about
this game yes I climbed up to like see
you plug in and crawl across the court
the vacuum would turn itself on go down
one screen and turn left see they even
made it to the game you can all tap
that noise is so irritating
frosty edge of work bridge go to the
corner and crawl down the legged
workbench to the horizontal brace have
the kaustubha all right so like how
would you even know how to do this
except trial and error Jesus Christ
ah Jesus oh sweet that's what happened
I might around my dam where am I now
all these cockroaches are freaking out
and it's up where you going
or go to everywhere the amount of
liquids just lying around on work
benches and floors and stuff is just
awful over the whole I don't think the
rank is particularly high in this
establishment who wants it here rat
babies I go and see the rat babies
fun's missing in bugspray research scan
a area really all right
we do all FMV games exist in San
Francisco it's two for two weird
alright fine see deceptive they bridge
then is this like happily he's 10 the
roads how can we
South Beach San Francisco said beach
area yeah I guess I guess this is taking
place and right and this makes sense
this looks like Tom you taught me to
save right voice of God is saying safe
Cindy
and not get onto the table this way No
that's right
then in this way what is this some more
goo it's the table I crawl up the table
[ __ ] the perspective in this game is
just the worst corner Rams yeah there's
a some sort of rag which considering the
amount of liquid around this place a
hazard to guess what was in him
fly squad she ticked like a timebomb is
into a saucy literature like I got high
on sleeping pills
in somebody's house
today's radio station
musics kinda weird
oh god it's just awful and delicious
No
come on spiders come at me
there's a lot of nothing in this game
there's a lot of seems to be a lot of
areas where you could just explore ways
to cut that life
all right you got so ominous to the
music down here is very ominous and the
cockroaches sputtering around I worry
there's some sort of Beast there's got
to come at me
that carpet can't crawled over carpet of
a cockroach
obviously here
God life is a cockroach's so titties
drop this wall
I didn't know what's going on anymore
sure
I don't think cockroaches already are
this Jesus Christ maneuverable and they
just straight-up crawl up walls like
this
yeah
I mean no that is window
animation sure doesn't like it
negligent hoping to be sticky
goddammit just random sticky fluid on
the wall this guy is really awful yeah
that's your mistake was stepping at this
man's wall semen it looks like it'll
kill me if I go near it
throw a rat in there
aramis if I don't see one
it's dr. Roger Simon's is that me dr.
sands can you tell me where you met a
bunch of kids I wish I could I'm as much
in the dark as you are all I know is the
money's here and I could finally fund my
research I'm happy the university's
happy hey I'm not gonna dis gift horse
in the mouth
I sure did like acid now you're a
cockroach
legs to wonder the concrete floor of
this man's geez dungeon
1994
oh it's shoe lots of dough that's I find
this racist okay go in there greenback
giveaway I don't call us greenbacks
that's not cool
I crawl now
God if it wasn't for goo cockroaches
gonna take it over the world
how long does a cockroach live they die
of boredom what the [ __ ] was that
Oh economy
my favorite part is the firework at the
end alright alright friends where we
going
vacuum cleaner plug okay I know where
that was I think that entire [ __ ] of
lying on the ground crawling around the
ground was completely redundant which is
fine because I've asked him I saved it
was actually closer to where we need to
meet so actually no what no not even
there I really need to go there this one
yeah
turn on the vacuum cleaner and then go
back down to the block
I turn it on with my super cockroach
powers there you go yeah
don't go to the
other side of the pageant there
right
go under the plugin next one go right
past the sticky Brad stuff
stinky brand stuff everywhere great
vacuum attachment crawl down to the
multicolored hose follow it along each
seat okay
that go across the price
they can go down this way
Oh
and then a negative workbench are
somebody's turn right and travelled
right across the bracelet in you come to
two black wires hanging over a yellow
pine road together yikes crawl down the
wire until you're able to drag the
exposed wire into the paint
I'm saving this is some pro nonsense I
gotta do sure
no every time I save the game it just
puts me on the right side of the screen
oh you know what I'm gonna try something
in him all right I'm wondering if I do
that on the vacuum cleaner level would
it just shoot me past the vacuum cleaner
I didn't skip this entire section
I'll get some [ __ ] dead that's
exactly what I'm gonna try this time
dude and use my super cockroach hacking
skills to get past this day aiden pearce
ain't got nothing on me alright so if i
save the game now there's a very high
chat this works it should shoot me over
to the right side of the screen and I
get has done every other time
hacking soon
got down at the one time I wanted a time
all right
no I'm going that way
got that noise irritating as hell
yeah
go this way got it all right so how do I
do this without getting murdered
fall down the wire until you're able to
drag the exposed wire it's the paint now
in the car it shorts out the vacutainer
okay it's just a little bit o physics
this is physics in 1994 [ __ ] dinner
I gotta turn off that awful noise all
right
I having
I got go in there now
yeah they taught me to do something else
but I don't care
also I'm gonna say and that time it did
it you're kidding me
and that time it butts up damn it all
this game is the worst
Lucca paints
or this way
I want me to go that way I wanna go that
way I keep going down nope
yes I can't go down all right blitzkrieg
beers that's not the insensitive
I was really awful it's like an episode
of Hoarders with cockroaches perspective
you can tell in these games when
something's like usable and you like
those wires look some difference
everything else that has to be some sort
of like that's gonna be animated right
it doesn't feel like I'm actually
crawling around this world it feels like
I'm crawling around a picture of this
world all right that way
now
all of this can pasta nope
what you saying great coil leading to
the rice did that top left into charge
this is a maze walk down around the
trash can back up over at the top right
of the trash can always stay on the
electrical conduit
now what I think I probably not supposed
to display I just feel like this some
sort of weird method of getting to this
just jump stupidly fear of the crawl on
friggin walls why can't you just there's
little more irritating than games when
just there is a physical barrier that
you can like feel like you just step
over but the came just won't let you
all right one this way now
in this way
we go yes doctor
I can't underneath the cup and I know
that's right
yes whoo okay look at this
this doesn't make any sense look how big
the cargo just here and then when I get
that far away I'm the same
Walker and stay away from the red goo
Oh
just
drue everywhere
and wastes a lot of paint are you son of
a
that in my dog
commit suicide
could be playing watchdogs could be
playing watchdogs I'm to blame for this
I could blame sake to me for this as
well oh gosh
really really I crawl up here No
there's a matter I can speedrun this bit
now see how pro I am at this maze
Rochin ain't easy it's just like the
like at least like okay the maze in
Secret of Monkey Island like yes it is
amazed that you randomly have to like go
up and left it down and right and stuff
but they made an interesting because
they had that whole the dance steps
which is what you read to figure out
where to go this is just tedious I'm
confused I don't know why I care about
this character this cockroach seems to
be really good and park chorong along
walls but can't get over a slightest bit
of liquid there's pain times what seems
to be bodily fluids everywhere
see I know what's gonna happen if things
are closed up again as they se like
[ __ ]
can't crawl on this chain it's
underneath me for some reason
it's beneath me no you stupid [ __ ] you
know what's irritating all the other
tables and chairs I was able to like
crawl down the underside of them but for
some reason this why cast
let's get across
back to the start if you thought that
speed run off the pipes was good that
time she I get this one keep getting
better man here we go
if you're joining us this is a the hot
new game from Ubisoft
bad mojo would you play a cockroach
embezzled money from my university and
has a cat who's an [ __ ] and lives in
San Francisco
yeah back here it's a favorite bed
look it just transported me again all
right what am I doing here boy
paintbrush avoiding the blue paint where
you see the yellow light shining through
the crack all right I did see them
I go this way
here
we were looking at dripping
SiC animation
help
when we wants shame on you I think I'm
supposed to go down that thing there
bristles
is there another screen here
Oh
whoa all I can't go underneath the thing
I just couldn't over there for some
redundant reason right
we need to find a crack god damn it
go up this way and turn around
there nope nope why not
it's a crack right there how do I get
over there a good friend that game
boomers calm sitting on the answer and
the pea brush is a black screen a table
move across the paint brush bristles go
down one screen avoiding the blue paint
we've left Tracy yellow light shine to
the crack to our left
but everyone jesus christ almighty
oh this is the least enjoyable video
game experience I've had quite a long
time no get out of the [ __ ]
yeah back in the tunnel better load up
my save game which one it oh yeah [ __ ]
this game not BMJ that's it yeah right
yeah red paint right
red paint right how long is this game
Jesus Christ
good going endgame that's a that's good
can we email G John one and aol.com at
game boomers and get him in here to play
the game Jesus Christ
it's actually not that loud all right
red spilled paints gotcha get off - yep
go straight down one screen until you
see a paintbrush crawl across the length
of the paintbrush on in and into the
black crack in the table length of the
paintbrush black crack
just making this up now aren't you
it's a black crack in the table just
back off just back off and above paint
brush bristles
another crack like that's not a crack
being like there may be more than one
paintbrush I was it there
there's the crack yay that wasn't
impossible to see it all guessing I go
in this one yes
ray
what hellish puzzle awaits me in this
next area
keep walking
I get to rotate these there's some sort
of electrical pairs I'll keep going
sure why not I remember that bit in the
walkthrough we say good and them up you
see that made my pandal all wait you do
have to do a thing okay yeah done that
done that done that okay the first one
is stationary number 72 shorted diffuses
by establishing the other three dial
setting six five eight go back to the
three red and blue fuses and run back
and forth across them until the dial
settings read it seven six five eight at
that time use the fuse box in the shore
-
it sounds like fun to me Jesus Christ
can often
where the numbers I can't see them how
do I see it back here
is it back here
everything sticky
can you guys see anything changing
because I can't see anything changing
laughs go up one screen on the glass
globe to look for for measuring dials
crawl across to the meter on the right
side
go up here it's not sticky like
everything else
goddammit
everything's sticky when I try and go up
and I just see them from here every look
it's got this thing
this chain I can call this Benito are
you sure you sure I can't stick her and
Claymore bad mojo reduct all right I
want to see what's at the end of this
thing if you want to learn if you want
to complete this puzzle for your very
self then feel free to pick up bad mojo
redux I'm sure the people who made this
game are still getting money first
eighteen years they're all G yeah you
know what
sure yeah sure evil bastard cash yeah
get to see that bit one more time before
I kill myself uh thanks for that
psychics um a button Oh char ducks is
available on gog.com for the low low
price of five dollars and ninety nine
cents check out that we didn't watch the
trailer sorry I'm I'm like we should
probably watch the trailer you can see
all the stuff you missed that on
gog.com staying is it but cheated
stepped on I was always the little man
the square peg that night right
everything was gonna change this is not
what the game looks like this is not
this is a disingenuous trailer
I was no longer
that's like sperm and a picture of his
mom like I just don't yep yep they have
them now on gog.com
what did gamespot give this oh Jesus
really superb 1994 it was a weird time
1996 there's like the Year gamespot it
was started right Jesus
striking the original bad mojo is a
gritty action based exploration that
sucks you in get it with great visuals
and keeps you playing with a poignant
story I don't know
I can't whoa is this the reviews are
like five words long back then I liked
it five people listening to this right
now
why not signed in I'm not alright I
don't know maybe it gets way better
maybe I'm giving this game bad shake
maybe I just suck at it all of these
things are probably true but all I want
to see is the ending so there's the odd
as multiple endings let's get the worst
ending
yes that's a pretty bad ending just yep
that'll do it
and the rest of San Francisco burnt down
I tried to show Roger that he had a
family and I tried to show Eddie that he
had something to live for but I failed
it's strange how people can be blind to
what's right in front of them now
they're both dead it's work and daddys
on the waterfront is gone
posed in the name of urban renewal and
progress on the spot where the bar once
stood
they built espresso bars and luxury oh
my god this game is foreshadowing the
gentrification of 1010 cypresses to roam
the spot where our dreams die all right
all right I mean that was okay what was
the good ending now I need to see the
good ending that's sheriff is the good
ending that or the dot-com crash got the
house prices were tragically high as
they are
because I gonna have to take back
everything I said about this game that's
the case look you're not a cockroach
anymore and edit tab with all your money
or invested in Google Facebook any of
these things
who knows twitch or twitch
yeah
yeah holy [ __ ] you're a cockroach there
for a long time never it up it will you
can't ate you
you killed up kill that spider with a
bitching with cigarette smoking oh it's
this shot again it's the thing going to
blow up but he gets out
they're Sam's didn't you smell the gas
Oh
and we're going to waste that special
effect on pad anything where'd you get
this how was my mother's
I gave back to her laughs your wonders
my Angelina No
you you're my father somebody watch Star
Wars my father's a piece of shirt
explain this I don't know let's get out
of here
Eddie told me about my mom and about the
night she died he felt so bad that he
gave me up without even thinking about
it he regretted that all these years I
felt kind of guilty about blowing up his
bar so it took him with me to Mexico how
much money could you possibly have had a
canteen in Belize where he does pretty
good with the tourists me right well I
set up a little lab down here to study
roaches in the rain forest and Eddie and
I get along yeah well they're really
they really spend all that budget on
sending them to Mexico for that one shot
at the end right okay that's been random
encounter this week thank you very much
for for hanging out during that offer
you could have been playing watchdogs
but you decided to stick around here and
I appreciate it
as George Lucas gonna come after us all
right
yeah probably happy
Rhonda McKenna day see you guys next
week if you have any suggestions tweet I
here's why I'm here bless your second
suit way in which keep the teaser no
thanks for the recommendation
I appreciate it that was interesting
I'll see you guys next week